Por qué marcar si genera tanta
resistencia en el ala más conservadora
de los republicanos
Muchísimas gracias Es un placer estar
aquí partido republicano tienen este
momento la posibilidad de del liderazgo
de Kevin McAllen que hasta este momento
se ha desempeñado como líder de La
minoría en esa cámara para ese partido y
que bueno tiene una gran experiencia en
el pasado
intentó hacerlo intentó llegar a esta
posición de presidente de la cámara de
representantes o como se le conoce de
manera más amplia speaker de la cámara
pero no lo pudo hacer Entonces en ese
momento encontró resistencia en muchos
de sus colegas de sus compañeros de
partido Y bueno pues salió por Ryan como
un candidato de consenso en esta ocasión
pienso que él tendría más posibilidades
que antes pero pero evidentemente no
tiene un seguro de vida en estas
aspiraciones porque ya vimos lo que pasó
en el 2015 hay unas hay hay discusiones
no y hay divisiones internas en el
partido y esto probablemente va a ser
que esta elección de él sea mucho más
difícil hay posibilidades que él pueda
los 218 votos que se requieren que se
necesitan para para obtener esta
posición de speaker Pero bueno ya muchas
cosas están por verse todavía y sin
lugar a dudas se necesita consenso en su
propia en su propia
corriente no en su propio partido
político Sí precisamente para conseguir
ese consenso consenso ha hecho
concesiones a los más radicales del
partido como ajustar las normas para una
moción de censura contra el presidente
de la cámara no debilitan estas
concesiones su postura como líder de
este órgano
por supuesto él está demostrando con
esto que tiene bastante ganancias por
llegar a la posición y él trató de
ocupar la posición en el 2015 como he
dicho y no pudo lograrlo de hecho en
este momento él ha realizado un un
borrador de las reglas que van a entrar
en juego en caso de que él pudiese
llegar a la posición y lo ha y lo ha
compartido con todos los colegas del
partido para que puedan leerlo y
evidentemente él está tratando de ganar
votos hay algunas personas que ya han
dicho que no van a apoyar a otra persona
que no sea él precisamente por el
trabajo de consenso y el trabajo de de
campo que él está haciendo en el en la
cámara baja de los representantes pero
si él no logra llegar a la posición se
convertiría en historia por ser el
primer caso de la persona que le pasa
esto dos veces en el mismo siglo
Y cómo afectará que los republicanos
ahora tengan la mayoría de la cámara de
representantes a la gobernabilidad de
Joe biden
es una pregunta bastante interesante y
para empezar habría que decir que la
gente legislativa de biden va a
enfrentar muchos obstáculos a pesar de
que cuentan con la mayoría demócratas en
la cámara alta escena de los Estados
Unidos pero para empezar recordemos que
en el que el próximo 20 de enero se
inicia el segundo tramo de la
presidencia de baile es decir se cierra
la primera mitad de su presencia en la
casa blanca e inicia una etapa crucial
que sin lugar a dudas es importante para
un presidente que quiere reelegirse para
las elecciones de dos años después no y
precisamente este presidente quiere
Mostrar logros quiere Mostrar recibir un
récord exitoso y al mismo tiempo que
está cumpliendo las promesas de campaña
promesas que evidentemente están
pendientes y sujetas a la palabra
empeñada en esos en esos procesos de
campaña y que están también sujetas a
reformas y diríamos también que a la
adopción de leyes nuevas entonces Esto
va a ser un poco
un obstáculo bastante importante habrá
confrontación no se pondrán de acuerdo
recibirá mucho más mucho más
mucho
más ataques de parte contrario porque la
gobernabilidad necesitará un mayor
margen de maniobra necesitará un mayor
un mayor nivel de poder consensual